Now let us try to understand what
altitudes are and where or not they meet at a
point consider a triangle a s if a segment AD
is drawn from vertex a to its
opposite side b s true that it is perpendicular
to b s then it is called  An
altitude so AD is one of the altitudes
of this triangle
remember it only has to be
perpendicular to the side d and may not be
the mid point of segment
bc8 b to segment a now if
the altitude from point c to
segment a passes through  This point we can see that
the altitudes of a triangle are coincident
cf2 to segment A and we can see that it passes
through the point Pat of intersection of
AD and
B All the altitudes of the triangle pass through
one single point Let's name that point
o  Let's Analyze This Figure Segments AD
B and CA are the altitude of this triangle which meet
at one single point and the
point where all the altitude meets is called
the ortho
center It's simple we just drop
perpendiculars from every vertex to
its opposite side and get the  Ortho Center
But This Was An Example Of An Acute
Triangle What If It's Not An Acute
Triangle Let's Understand It With A
Recording From Math
Open.com This Is An Acute Triangle As
Three Perpendiculars Are Drawn From Each
Vertex To The Opposite Side And All  The
Altitude Meets at the Ortho Center Which Lies
Inside the Triangle Does the
Ortho Center Always Lie Inside the
Triangle Let's Move Vertex A Towards the
Left to Form a Right Angle at B Now It
Gets
Interesting This is the Altitude from
Vertex B to the Opposite Side  a c but what about the
other two altitude where does the
ortho center lie this segment from vertex
a to b is one of the altitude this
altitude does not
lie in between b and c it lies on point b and
this segment is the altitude from
Vertex c to segment a and again it meets
segment a at point
b all the three altitudes meet at point b
in a right angle triangle the vertex at the
right angle will be the ortho
center let's make it even more interesting we move
vertex a left words  To make
angle b b obtuse this segment is an altitude
from vertex b to side a
but to drop a perpendicular from vertex a to
segment b we have to extend c b
so this segment becomes the altitude from
vertex a similarly to drop an
altitude  From vertex C we had to extend a
After we drew all the altitude we had to extend
each one to form the
ortho center This proves that in an obtuse triangle
the ortho center lies
outside the triangle and the more the
triangle gets the further away  The ortho center
will lie from the
triangle so if the triangle is a right angle the ortho
center will lie inside the triangle in the
case of a right triangle it will lie on the
vertex at the right angle and if the triangle is right angled the ortho center will lie inside the triangle.
The
triangle let's understand this again this
is a right triangle as a is the altitude
from vertex a on to side b s cb
is the altitude from vertex
c on to side a and let this be the
altitude from vertex b on to side
a  All the three altitudes meet at point B which is
the ortho
center. Now this is an adjacent triangle as we can
drop an altitude from
vertex B to side A but to drop an
altitude from a we need to extend C
B and this becomes the  Altitude from
vertex a to b s and again to drop n
altitude from vertex c to a we need to extend a and then
drop n altitude
from vertex c now we have a
three
altitudes to find the ortho center v
extend each of them down words v
Extend the altitude from A and then we
extend the altitude from B backwards and then we
extend the altitude from
C All of them meet at one point which is the
ortho
[music]
center